at some point during the run of the wire
i became a fellow traveler of the
libertarians
and and then a great disappointment to
them in that and that we were
and then that we were to continue that
[Music]
way
i'm nick gillespie with reason tv and
today we're sitting with david simon
the acclaimed writer producer and
creator of the wire
a series that ran on hbo for five
seasons and is considered by
many critics to be the best tv show of
all time a former baltimore sun reporter
he's also the author of homicide a year
on the killing streets
which was later turned into a series for
nbc and he wrote and produced the hbo
miniseries the corner
simon's current project is treme which
is starting its third season on hbo
uh the series offers a multi-faceted
look at new orleans after hurricane
katrina david thanks for joining us
thanks for having me let's talk about
treme watching the
the first three seasons of the show i
kept thinking of the faulkner line about
how the past isn't dead
in the south that has even passed and
your show seems to be
very much focused on people who are
trying to maintain
or keep consistent and true new orleans
culture but then there's also a stark
recognition that things have to change
you are correct there is always a
tension be you know between
tradition in the past and and
and and organic creativity
and i think uh that's probably true in
any city but it's
it's particularly dynamic in new orleans
and and the
the amazing thing about new orleans is
they're not willing to let anything go i
mean there's still bands that are
right down there that are playing does
that make them kind of like cultural
hoarders where
you know if you're you know full of crap
like you can
and i don't mean you know it's just
stacked to the gills if it were crap
yeah nothing new if it were crap yes but
no i mean if you're if you're familiar
with their actual culture
um the music scene down there is more
dynamic pound for pound
than any i've ever seen in the world i
mean i mean
there is a punk sea shanty band
which shows up in the show yeah actually
we did them one morning
a punk sea shanty band i mean on some
level
that's just gorgeous right that's just
that's just you know only
only in new orleans as they say you know
it's a complex text as i think treme
when i first started watching it i have
to say i saw the john goodman character
and i was like wow this is
awful i mean this is a white guilt
liberal
and i was kind of happy when he died uh
in the end of the first season
you might want to reflect on that i i
believe me i will
uh i will but in in the sense that the
show completely and i was obviously
looking at him
very quickly the show is very the reason
that i think the wire was intriguing to
to a lot of people once they found it
and not initially intriguing at all to
many people
but once they found it once they
realized it was actually
shaped a little bit differently than
television entertainment one of the
things that
we did was we were not interested in
straw men
right so you could look at it you could
be a conservative and you could come
to some conclusions that gratified you
now i would not agree with the
conclusions but there was at least
evidence in there for you to proceed
down your path
and be moderately content with the
storytelling you could do that if you
were liberal you could do that if you
were a socialist you could do that if
you were a libertarian
you could find things where you felt as
if you were traveling with
with with good fellas um
that doesn't mean that it didn't have a
point of view that doesn't mean that
it's a it's a
it's truly a an empty tablet
right um but
the trick to making anything that
matters is to not
treat treat the the source material
as if it's your own um
as if you can indulge your own political
dialectic
by picking and choosing um because the
world is more complicated than that
and that's a rigor that that we have
with all you know there are a lot of
people
a lot of people a lot of people who are
very opposed to the iraq war
as an intervention and i was opposed to
the iraq war as a uh
as a as a war of choice um some of them
had a hard time with the initial uh
episodes of generation kill
the marines are very profane they very
much are hungry to go to war it's what
they do it's what we train them for i i
don't blame them in the slightest
and they wanted a dissertation from from
ed burns and david simon
and and evan wright about why this war
was wrong
i don't know how to write for that kind
of person i'm not interested in writing
for that kind of person i'm only
interested in writing for the kind of
person who first wants to know
what was it like for the marines and who
are these guys right that's
that's job one you know and when john
goodman says things like san francisco
is a
a cesspool with hills that's a clue
you know san francisco is one of the
most beautiful cities in the world but
it's very hard to do tv on that level
because
most people expect american tv they
expect somebody to say something
and they expect somebody to write
afterwards say that's not right you know
and
to actually correct the record almost
within the scene what is it about the
hbo model that actually allows for a
kind of balzac
and complexity to emerge exactly no it
is i mean this is you just call me a
ball sack
i called you a ball size yeah i thought
i thought i knew we were going to get
down
yeah that was this is so now that let's
take damn you libertarians
no but what i mean what is it about hbo
and other i mean you know and this is
part of the irony right is that it this
is always it's in a place where you got
to pay more but then you get better
art it seems that you do on free tv
that's all that's all
true of all tv yeah uh i didn't used to
pay for television 25 years ago i had
rabbit ears like you did yeah
uh and it beamed three or four channels
in and
and that was what you got uh and when
they hooked you up to the cable
and they began they created a revenue
stream they were able to create more
programming
it was a it was a remarkably shrewd and
effective way of
expanding the television universe um and
for the better right
uh and i would argue that uh
tellingly um newspapers as an industry
went the opposite way what happened with
newspapers in the industry was
wall street
the great sin was taking what were
community-based
family-owned newspapers joining the
linking them together in chains
making them public companies and going
to wall street with them because wall
street did to the
industry of newspapering what they did
to other industries which is when you
say wall street i mean are you
i mean do you mean the tribune company
or yeah you mean no i mean the animals
i mean i mean the operating dynamic of
wall street
i don't i'm not i'm saying the dynamic
capitalism
right talk to any baltimorean about what
the baltimore sun has become with 100
there are 130 people over at that
newsroom now there used to be 600
there used to be now you want to say
they could have gone down to 500 once
they stopped publishing
what are we arguing about right at a
certain point nobody's covering the city
courthouse at a certain point i mean
this is i
you know and i don't know baltimore i
know a lot of people at the los angeles
times and it would be hard to say that
that newspaper is any worse than it was
in 1995 or 1955 because
it had always been a booster i don't
know what to say to you yeah i don't
know what to say to you you're bringing
you you're bringing things that are not
rooted in pierce you have some emotional
disconnect now i'm just saying that the
l.a times has always been first and
foremost a booster for the idea of los
angeles
you're bringing some sort of weird
ideology into it yeah
no actually i think that's something
some opinion about well
i'm the what are you do i mean i'm
bringing i'm bringing the amount of
ground covered
that's what i'm interested you know i
never had everyone imagines
some sort of if you have you ever worked
in a newspaper
yeah which one i worked in a couple of
newspapers in new jersey briefly uh the
home news in new brunswick was
the one that's still in business okay
right back did you ever work at like a a
newspaper
like do you think there's like an agenda
in a newsroom where no i don't
right the agenda okay the agenda is
when it's healthy and and and when you
have enough to do and you have enough
people to do it
the agenda is to cover the ground and to
cover it smarter
and to find out what really the [ __ ] is
going on and it's a very imperfect
science and
and and you fail as much as you succeed
but
you know like anything worth trying and
like with anything worth doing
you fail as much as you succeed but i
never had anybody say to me
we're doing this and we and we think
this is good or we think this is bad
they basically just planted me on the
beat and they planted
five of us on the crime beat there was a
there was a court reporter every day
that you could
work with you know the city courts which
were inextricably linked
there were three police reporters at any
given moment there was
there were ga reporters that could be
thrown into law enforcement issues
and we covered more ground mm-hmm
there's one guy left
there's one guy he's working his house
no i i see the absolute logic
the baltimore sun that's true at the st
louis post dispatch that's true at the
cleveland plain dealer that's true with
los angeles
what i'm saying is that when you might
have more people covering stuff but you
did not have a moment where the los
angeles times
was somehow a more uh uh
and it doesn't need to be negative but i
don't know that it was interrogating the
power structure in los angeles
when it had twice as many reporters
writing about it
if you want to critique what they didn't
do no but
what i'm saying is that if the person
there's there's a fallacy in what you're
saying and what i'm saying though is
that now
you can read many sources coming out of
los angeles including the los angeles
times i think
probably city hall and the power
structure is
more aptly covered than it was under a
traditional model where
i couldn't disagree more yeah and i can
and i can only cite what's going on in
baltimore right
okay there's more commentary there's
more debate
there's more discussion the internet is
a great
democratization there's also more
first-hand reporting observations i
don't know what to tell you
it's not happening here in the city in
which you were sitting it's not
happening in new orleans
it's not happening in any city where
mainstream media has
retrenched it is not happening one of
the things that was striking in a recent
interview you did with bill moyers you
said
you know i don't believe in institutions
anymore you're cynical about those and
i'm paraphrasing but that you believe in
individuals
yet your understanding of society which
is one of the reasons why you know i
called you a ball sack uh you know and i
meant to balls act because
you know fundamentally but i am a
ballsack you know well i'm not going to
parse that but uh
you know but you know fundamentally your
work
is about institutions of power
and of and movement and not you know
it's on all different levels but what is
the solution have you
have you boxed yourself in where you no
if you don't believe in
institutions then no see i'm a grown-up
how do i
change things i am a grown-up okay and
it comes down to this
and this is where i really you know it's
where i get exhausted with the notion of
well there's been corruption there so
let's throw up our hands
and declare that this is too much
government
this is how government does it what is
your freaking alternative
there is never going to be permanent
institutional stasis where something's
always everything will corrode
everything will rust
everything will need to be replaced
everything will need to be challenged
and continually uh policed
you know freedom somebody much wiser
than me my father used to say this at
every single passover seder he this was
his one
bit of wisdom he never let a year go by
without saying it was
freedom can never be entirely won
ever but it can be lost and the way in
which you lose it
i've come to believe is not by
acknowledging the inevitability
of communal action and community and
it's institutional necessity
but it's by walking away from our
ownership our collective ownership
our collective assertions of demand on
the performance of that institution
let me ask you this though because and
again i mean things like charter schools
things like
school vouchers or getting out where you
can get on a lifeboat or the last free
school
out of casablanca these are libertarian
ideas there's way
of of changing the institution so they
serve the individuals they're supposed
to serve
if it's funded if if you're willing if
you want to take the same dollar
that you were giving to a public schools
you know we have not stinted on
increasing the amount of money we spend
per pupil over the past 40 years we have
nothing
literally you will not get me defending
the performance of public energy but to
bring it back to treme
but the idea of public education is
lowercase p lowercase you know milton
friedman is the
the godfather of the school choice
movement and you know that's
you know so he'll have to answer for
that one though
well yeah he has uh a few things to
answer for but
in treme though so in the arc of the
series and as we go through the third
season
would you say that you start to show the
green shoots of where the people
because at every level and in different
cases everything is corrupt i mean the
public sector the private sector
individual morals are corrupted
aesthetics and
individuals start doing what they can
and there is nothing in the wire
and there is nothing in treme that
argues against individual responsibility
towards the collective and that's where
i find
uh patriotism and find citizenship you
know
you're not seeing people in treme in
season three begin to police themselves
and to make their neighborhood safer
that that's beyond their capabilities
for that they need law enforcement
professionals
but you do see them start to stand up on
their hind legs and say the way you're
behaving as an institution is
unacceptable
and though and creating alternatives i
mean they're building their businesses
or they're creating art that is
empowering
themselves and the people around them i
mean well they're they're they're
seeking reform
yeah um and sometimes that involves
trying to reform the necessary
institution
and some sometimes you know certainly in
the private sector uh if they're
starting a new
business um that's a new business yeah
you know i i'm not arguing against
uh venture capitalists right what i am
arguing against
in that piece is disaster capitalism you
know or disaster socialism as uh
and the two things may be inextricably
linked disaster socialism i mean the
amount of money and part of this is part
of treme is that
the amount of public money that came
that floods into new orleans and the way
that that gets diverted
from meaningful purpose well where do
you think he went
yeah well no i'm saying but you know it
i know it actually got to people oh no
no that's what i'm saying but i know
where it came from
and it came from the government and it
came from taxes so that that's
an aspect of i mean i think we're
talking about twin sides of the same
process
listen let's let's journey journey down
this road together because
louisiana is the is the jurisdiction in
the world
right that that jails more human beings
per capita
right than any other more than you know
so in the in the gulag
nation of the world it is the chinese
that's what i'm saying and then
louisiana is louisiana puts the rest of
america to shame right
that's a function of that's pure market
forces
there's profit to be made they've
monetized the poor down there that's
what they've done
they've left it last day fair hey we put
these laws on the books if you get
locked up
you know prison industries for you and
we're going to make money off you well
now we're all paying for that right but
people are getting rich
yeah well i mean and i would say again
i'm not shifting jurisdictions here but
in california the single most uh
powerful group
in state government is the state prison
guard union right and they're not
lobbying to get people
in and they were they were damn near
bankrupted the state with
with uh you know look at the rockefeller
laws look at the drug war sure
there are some things that the market is
not supposed to
dictate sure but i mean it is it the
market or is it you know
wait wait in the case of immigrant uh
you know incarceration and deportations
i mean that's the obama administration
which has
you know almost doubled the rate at
which george george bush
so that i mean i i understand where
you're coming from but i also i mean it
just seems to me that it's
missing you know these people might be
drafting off of
uh policies that are put in place ahead
of time i don't think that's right
nelson rockefeller didn't need drug laws
to get rich or to make his cronies right
now he was doing that before no he
needed them to get elected to uh final
final
final but i agree with that i absolutely
agree with that you know
the the if you know again it's got to be
across the board
right politicians will follow the path
of least resistance
if you let them and if you it if you
reward them for that
the whole idealized notion that
the private sector can do this better
than government i don't want the private
sector doing prisons better than
government i want government doing that
doing it reluctantly right you know i
want my prison department i want my
corrections department the state of
maryland or any state that i'm in
to be a reluctant agent of government
you know you were you were talking you
were disappointed with obama
president obama has said that the wire
is his favorite show i'm disappointed
with him in some ways
i'm very proud of him in other ways well
what i was going to ask particularly
about drug laws
um you know first off do you see any uh
do you see the
the positive trends i mean there's
marijuana legalization initiatives out
there
well the only positive trend that i see
that really matters
is i think more people are calling
[ __ ]
and this is where i you know um
i at some point during the run of the
wire i became a fellow traveler of the
libertarians yeah
and and then a great disappointment to
them in that and that we were
and then that we were hoping to continue
that and that we
on occasion but but the libertarian
position on drugs absolutely works
it absolutely works on on on personal
privacy and on
you know because it's because it's right
it's correct it's morally correct
do you take obama at his word that the
wire is his favorite show because it
seems odd that he
and eric holder as well it seems odd
that they would have watched the show
and then be pursuing the policies that
they had and not to make it a
one direction i do i do take
i i don't know about eric holder well i
do take him at his word because he had
the actors there and he knew the show
right and the actors told me the show
and i don't disagree with obama's
fundamental politics or his
some of his purposes i'll be voting for
obama
you know i i have a choice of two you
know i'm not wasting my vote
it can always get worse do you think new
orleans is getting better i mean because
the show is
is a couple years back in time but i
mean new orleans actually the
number of people who have returned is
higher than the initial projections or
expectations
is it is it actually uh flourishing it
depends on who you are
it depends on new york you know they
called the area
that didn't go under the water the
sliver by the river the isle of denial
um and
there is a uh schizophrenia i mean you
go out to gentilly and there are blocks
where you know you'll see
two or three people back and house after
house that are still not restored
um but new orleans before the storm 77
of the population was born there that's
unheard of in america
you know everyone's from somewhere else
in this country um
but if you're born there if you grow up
with that culture if you grow up with
that essence
it's very hard to say goodbye to it and
a lot of stuff's coming i mean again
it's not a museum piece
the number of latinos central americans
and mexicans that came into new orleans
to do construction work after katrina
and now it's stayed on you're going to
start seeing
some version of the mariachi second line
band you know and it won't just be on
cinco de mayo it'll be
it'll be i mean they're now going to
contribute to the musical culture and to
the cuisine and
you know new orleans is is
again all the attendant problems of the
american city and of
and i think city living is is is what
americans
have to master but man they make it hard
and i think that's the 21st century
challenge among other things
there's a lot of 21st century challenges
don't overstate it but that's one of
them for us
is how do we learn to love the city
for what it is because we have the
choice
well on that note david simon uh creator
of treme
uh most recently thank you for talking
to reason tv i'm nick gillespie
thank you
[Music]
you